you
you
before getting start have heard of
Zappos prior to this and how many of you
have actually shopped with us before Wow
very cool so normally when I do the
survey to a random group of people the
ratio is actually about two to one women
to men and a lot of women i vas or men
that I asked say they haven't personally
shop from us but their wife or
significant other has and a lot of times
it's this and if another buying for the
guy and I was actually giving a tour in
Las Vegas a little a few years ago to an
executive from one of the major record
labels and we actually were based out of
Las Vegas so next time any of you are in
Las Vegas would definitely recommend
coming for tour it's actually a lot of
fun I will pick you up from the airport
in as a post shuttle give you a tour
takes about an hour and then drop you
off at your hotel afterwards so anyways
we're doing this for an executive from
one of the major record labels and I
happen to be giving the tour and I asked
him the exact same question how do you
shop from us before and he said no he
hadn't but he suspects his wife has
because these white boxes would show up
on his doorstep and then they disappear
and he didn't know what was going on was
you know if she was buying them or
exchanging them returning them and every
time he asked his wife she would just
change the subject or refuse to answer
him and so you know giving the tour
downstairs is the merchandising area and
then we walk upstairs to our customer
loyalty team which is our name for our
call center and as we're walking through
like I started to explain stuff and then
turn around and he's gone and I'm like
what happened and I find out that he
actually went down one of the aisles and
sat down next to one of our reps and
forced her to pull up his wife's account
and so
and he felt it turned out he discovered
she had spent over 62 thousand dollars
in her lifetime so yeah hopefully we
weren't instrumental in any divorce
proceedings so and then as was mentioned
I have a book hunt that came out a few
months ago called delivering happiness
and we're actually on this three-month
cross-country bus tour we got this 50
foot bus and actually have some pictures
to show you we wrapped the bus there's
10 of us on the bus and we've gone
through I think 10 cities so far and and
and we and the inside I don't think I
have any inside pictures of the bus but
this is the delivering happiness book
team and it's actually its own mini
startup there's about 20 of us and 10 of
us are on the bus on anyone at any one
points so if you want to find out more
information just go to delivering
happiness bus comm and also delivering
happiness book calm there's fun videos
and pictures and so on there and and oh
yeah this is also a fun video to watch
if you have the time and I'll make this
presentation available so you can check
out the video later but we're actually
the buses of in Miami right now so I'll
be meeting back up with the bus at the
end of this week
but before getting into Zappos wanted to
talk about what led me to Zappos and the
story actually begins in college with
pizza I was running a pizza business on
the ground floor of my dorm in college
and with my roommate Sanjay he and I
decided to invest in pizza ovens and
it's this area that was set aside we
probably had three or four hundred
students in our dorm and the way it
would work is every year there'd be a
new set of students that would run that
grew it was called the grill area
downstairs and so one year we had we
were the highest bidders and we bought
it from the owners the from the previous
year and we decided to invest in pizza
ovens and we hired other students set
the menus dealt with suppliers and so on
and occasionally I was making the pizzas
myself and this guy named Alfred who
actually is the chief financial officer
today at Zappos he would stop by every
night and order large pepperoni pizza
from
and this is actually how we met and to
me it actually wasn't that weird he was
doing it because I had heard about his
reputation and he was known to actually
eat it really eat a lot of food he had
nicknames like monster human trash
compactor and literally there'd be nice
when there'd be ten of us late night at
a Chinese restaurant and he would just
finish everyone's leftovers so you know
not that word but then sometimes a few
hours later he'd come by and order
another large pepperoni pizza for me and
I was like wow this boy can really eat
well I found out several years later
alfred was taking the pizzas up stairs
and selling them off by the slice so
that's why he's our chief financial
officer anyway so after the pizza
business then Sanjay and I who I was
running in piece of business with we got
together and formed a company called
link exchange and this was during the
first you know calm craziness and we
grew that to about a hundred or so
people and then ended up selling the
company to Microsoft two and a half
years later but what a lot of people
don't know is the real reason why we
ended up selling the company and the
real reason is because it just wasn't a
fun place to work at anymore and the
company culture just went completely
downhill I remember when it was just
five or ten of us it was your typical
calm is a lot of fun we were working
around the clock sleeping under our
desks had no idea what day of the week
it was trying to remind ourselves to
shower occasionally but lots of fun and
as we were growing we hired friends and
friends of friends and I remember there
was a friend of mine that was on a
cross-country trip from New York and
this was all out of our apartment here
in San Mateo at the time and he stopped
by to help out and then he actually
never made his way back home he ended up
joining the company and that works
really well until we got to about 20
people we were having a lot of fun and
then we ran into a really big problem
when we got to 20 people and the problem
was basically we ran out of friends and
so we're trying to figure out here what
do we do now we didn't know how to hire
people and so we started just figuring
it out on our own and we ended up hiring
actually all the people with the right
skill sets and Experian
but they weren't all necessarily great
for the company culture and by the time
we got to a hundred people
I myself dreaded getting out of the bed
in the morning to go to the office and
that's kind of a weird feeling because
this is a company I co-founded and I
felt like you know if I felt that way
how much did all the other employees
feel
so that's really what led us to sell the
company to Microsoft and after the sale
myself Sanjay and most of the early
employees we all left the company
shortly thereafter so after that sale
you've worked out well financially
trying to figure out okay now what do we
want what do I want to do with my life
and I'm the type of person that gets
bored real easily and always excited by
new ideas and so alpha and I got
together and we formed a fund and invest
in about 20 or so different internet
companies and in my mind I was like well
this is a great way to really just get
exposed to a lot of different businesses
and ideas and so on and making the
investments was actually pretty exciting
pretty fun there was always some new
ideas some new business and this was in
the beginning of the internet days but
then after we had made all the
investments and there wasn't any money
left to invest in the fund I realized
that at that point and for me at least
investing was pretty boring I felt like
I was sitting on the sidelines and I
really miss being part of building
something so started think about what do
I want to do and out of all the
companies we had invested in Zappos
happen to be one of them and it was both
the most exciting and the most promising
so basically within a year I joined
Zappos full-time and I've been with
Zappos ever since some of you may have
heard it was about a year ago that
Amazon announced they were acquiring
Zappos and except it's actually very
different from most acquisitions that
Amazon has done in the past in most of
their acquisitions the plan is to
integrate the company being acquired
into the parent company and then
eventually the original company kind of
loses its identity and everything's
integrated into the mothership and
absorbed there whereas for us as a
precondition for even considering to
explore the deal we told them that we
would only consider it if Zappos could
remain independent if we could continue
to grow our brand and
culture and our way of doing business
our way and the great news is they've
remained true to their words so from our
point of view it's just as if we swapped
out our Board of Directors for a new one
so once a quarter instead of flying to
the Bay Area we now fly to Seattle once
a quarter for the equivalent of a board
meeting so most people when they hear
about Zappos think of us as an online
retailer of shoes because that's how we
started but internally we actually have
a different mentality we have a saying
that we're a service company that just
happens to sell shoes and in fact we
sell a lot more than shoes we sell
clothing beauty products housewares
kitchen wares and and and so on and
we're actually hoping ten years from now
people won't even realize we start out
selling shoes online we really just want
to build the Zappos brand to be about
the very best customer service and
customer experience and in fact it
doesn't even have to be limited to
online we've actually had customers
email us and asked us if we would please
start an airline or run the IRS and no
we're not going to do either of those
things this year but 20 or 30 years from
now I wouldn't rule out as Apple's
Airlines that's just about the very best
customer service and customer experience
so one brand that we look to for
inspiration sometimes is virgin they're
in a whole bunch of different businesses
you know music airlines and so on the
difference is the Virgin brand is more
about being hip and cool whereas we just
want to be about the very best customer
service so our whole philosophy is let's
take most of the money that we would
have spent on paid advertising or paid
marketing and rather than by our
exposure instead let's invest it into
customer service in the customer
experience and let our customers do the
marketing for us through word-of-mouth
on any given day about 75% of our orders
are from repeat customers and we
basically grew from no sales in 1999 to
in 2008 was the first year where we hit
a billion dollars in gross merchandise
sales and actually even despite the bad
economy we've actually continued to grow
over the last two years in fact our net
sales for q1 this year we're up almost
50% year-over-year and people ask us
what do we do differently over the last
24 months and it's actually we actually
didn't do anything differently and it's
not because of anything we did over the
past two years it's because of all the
investment
we made prior to that that we continued
to grow because of the loyalty of our
customers and the number one driver of
all that growth is through repeat
customers and word-of-mouth so these are
some of the questions that we ask
ourselves in terms of thinking about how
to deliver great customer service and we
internally use the word Wow when
thinking about how would you treat
customers but we use it as a verb we
talk about how do we allow our customers
and also how do we well our employees
and the vendors that we work with and it
starts with the policies you see on our
website we offer free shipping both ways
so a lot of people will order 10
different pairs of shoes try them on in
the comfort of their living room with 10
different outfits and then send back the
ones that don't fit or they don't like
and we encourage that type of behavior
we have a 365 day return policy for
people that I guess have trouble
committing or making up their minds and
you know they can take well to to return
products and you know most websites it's
very hard to find contact information
usually it's buried 5linx deep and maybe
it's an email address you can only email
once whereas for us we take the exact
opposite approach we put our 1-800
number on the top of every single page
of our website because we actually want
to talk to our customers and it's funny
because sometimes I'll be speaking at a
branding or marketing conference and
there's a lot of discussion about
consumers being bombarded with thousands
and thousands of marketing messages
every day how do you get your message to
stand out how to get your brand to stand
out in you know should they be investing
millions of dollars in this 30 second
Superbowl ad that people may or may not
be paying attention to or should they be
leveraging the latest in the social
media fad and for us as kind of low-tech
and unsexy as it may sound we found that
the telephone is actually one of the
best branding devices out there because
we have the customers undivided
attention for 5 to 10 minutes and if we
get the interaction right we find that
the customers remember that for a very
long time and tell their friends and
family about us and we run our call
center very differently for most call
centers we don't have scripts we don't
have this concept of average handle time
which most call centers have which is
all about how quickly can you get the
customer off the phone and the name of
being more efficient but we're not
trying to maximize for efficiency we're
trying to maximize for the customer
experience and we don't upsell and so
going back to the note Calton actually
just got an email last night a new
record was set for the longest phone
call ever it was eight hours and three
minutes long so yeah I don't know how
the bathroom situation worked effort for
that one but so and it may seem weird
that you know for us we're an Internet
company 95% of our sales go through the
website so why do we focus so much on
the telephone and what we found is
actually on average almost every
customer calls us at least once sometime
during their lifetime and it's actually
usually not to place an order
most of our phone calls do not result in
orders it might be the first time going
through the returns process and they
just need help stepping through the
process of printing out the return label
for the first time or maybe they have a
wedding over the weekend and they just
want some fashion advice and I think we
have some customers that call us because
they're lonely and well we'll talk to
them as well so so that's our call
center and then for our warehouse we
actually run it very differently from
most warehouses as well most warehouses
they let the orders pile up so that when
the picker needs to walk around there's
hire picking density more efficient
doesn't need a walk as far for us we run
our warehouse 24/7 which is not the most
efficient way to run your warehouse and
but we're not trying to maximize for
efficiency and because we run it 24/7
and because our warehouse is located in
Kentucky right next to the UPS hub and
because we do these surprise upgrades to
overnight shipping for a lot of most of
our repeat loyal customers when you
combine all three of those things a lot
of customers order as late as midnight
Eastern Time and the shoe show up on
their doorstep eight hours later when
they're expecting it a week later and
that creates that whole emotional
response we're trying to be listed in
that Wow experience that causes them to
remember us for a very long time and
tell their friends and family about us
so for all this focus on customer
service and building our brand to be
about customer service custom
service is actually not the number one
priority of the company our number one
priority is company culture and our
whole belief is that if you get the
culture right most of the other stuff
like delivering great customer service
or building along a long-term enduring
brand will just happen naturally on its
own and our belief is that a company's
culture and a company's brand are really
just two sides of the same coin the
brand is just a lagging indicator of the
culture and if you think of you know
asked random people about what they
think of the airline industry as a whole
and usually you'll get back responses
about bad customer service or apathetic
employees and so on and like it or not
that is the brand of the industry even
though no airline set out for that to be
their brand so we really focus on
getting the culture right so what are
some of the things that we do to really
help build our culture well it starts
with the hiring process everyone that's
hired in our headquarters in Las Vegas
doesn't matter what position you need
accountant lawyer software developer you
go through the exact same training as
our call center reps one of the weeks is
actually later on when we send you to
Kentucky and you do all the different
warehouse functions picking packing
shipping receiving and so on but the
first four weeks before you start your
actual job we do call center training
and we go over a company history the
importance of company culture our
philosophy about customer service and
then you're actually on the phone for
two weeks taking calls from customers
and the reason why we have everyone do
that is because if we're serious about
building our brand to be about the very
best customer service and customer
experience then customer service
shouldn't just be a department it should
be the entire company and the other
great thing about that is during our
busy q4 holiday season which is now
coming up people from all different
departments can and do help out and they
hop on the phones that help answer the
phone calls so that means we don't need
a higher temps that may be bad for our
culture where you don't need a higher
temps that may not deliver the same
level of customer service that we're
looking for the other thing that we do
is at the end of the training we
actually make an offer to the entire
class and the offer is this we will pay
you actually it starts at the beginning
the end of the first week of training
they've been there for a week and the
offer is we will pay you for that week
you've spent training plus a bonus of
$2,000
to quit and leave the company right now
and that's a standing offer until the
end of the training and then we raise it
to $3,000 and extended a couple months
beyond that as well and the reason we
initially did this was because we didn't
want employees that were there just for
a paycheck
and starting pay in Las Vegas is $11 an
hour there's plenty of other call
centers there and so it's a pretty
significant amount of money and on
average we found out actually about 2 or
3 percent of people end up taking the
offer the offer started several years
ago at $100 and we actually keep upping
the offer because we feel like not
enough people are taking the offer but
what surprised us in what we didn't
realize was that actually the biggest
benefit came from the people who didn't
take the offer because they still had to
go home talk to their friends and family
and ask themselves is this a company
that I really believe in is this a
company that I want to be a part of and
whose culture I want to contribute to
and when they decide to turn down the
easy money what we found is when they're
back in the office on Monday there was
that much more passionate and engaged
and and really that by far that's been
the biggest benefit for us that we
didn't even expect and doing that but
before someone gets started at Zappos
before they go through the training we
actually interview everyone in two sets
of separate interviews the first set of
interviews for someone is kind of
standard stuff the hiring manager and
his or her team will interview for fit
within the team relevant experience
technical ability and so on but the
second set of interviews is done by our
HR department looking purely for culture
fit and they have to pass both in order
to be hired
so we've passed on a lot of really smart
talented people that we know can make an
immediate impact on our top or bottom
line but if they're not good for our
culture we won't hire them and the
reverse is true too we'll fire someone
if they're bad for our culture even if
they're doing their specific job
function perfectly fine even if they're
a superstar in their job function if
they're bad for the culture will fire
them just for that reason
and in our performance reviews are 50%
based on whether you're living and
inspiring the Zappos culture and others
the other thing we have is something
called a culture book and make that
freely available give you information
later on about that but it's something
we put out once a year and we ask all of
our employees to write a few paragraphs
about what the Zappos culture means to
them and except for typos it's unedited
so it includes the good in the bad and
it's organized by departments so you can
kind of see how the accounting culture
might be slightly different from the
warehouse culture so kind of like when
you go to Amazon and you read customer
reviews of products these are
essentially employee reviews of the
company we're also very active on
Twitter if you go to Twitter Apple is
calm you can see there's a page there we
have about 500 employees that are active
on Twitter we introduce every employee
to Twitter during the training and then
it's up to them whether they want to
continue using it but then we have a
page that aggregates all the employee
tweets together and so the way that's
helped our culture is you may not talk
to that person that's three aisles down
from you except for saying hi in the
hallway but through Twitter you might
find out that you went hiking over the
weekend and if you're also an avid hiker
now you have something to talk about and
you might go hiking together so those
are some of the things that we do on the
company culture side in terms of growing
our brand over the next several years we
have what we internally refer to as the
three C's clothing customer service and
company culture and really we think of
this as in terms of the life cycle of
the customer so customers that have
never heard of Zappos before have no
idea what we do we want them to know
that we've got a great selection of
clothing footwear in other product
categories once they know about our
selection then we want them to know that
we're all about delivering the very best
customer service which isn't something
that we tell them so much as something
that they experience when they get that
you know see how easy that free shipping
both ways is or get that surprise
upgrade to overnight shipping or talk to
one of our customer loyalty reps and see
that the person on the other end truly
wants to provide great service and once
they know that we're all about
delivering the very best customer
service then we want them to know about
our culture and core values which is
essentially a formalized definition of
our culture because that's really the
platform that makes all of that possible
so we've actually had customers
tell us that when they get that perfect
outfit or perfect pair of shoes that
Zappos is happiness in a box so whether
it's the happiness that customers feel
from getting that perfect outfit or
perfect pair of shoes or the happiness
that customers get feel from
experiencing great customer service or
the happiness that employees feel from
being part of the culture where the
personal values match their own where
their personal values match the
corporate core values the thing that we
realize ties all these things together
is that Zappos is really just about
delivering happiness whether it's to
customers employees we apply that same
philosophy to our vendors as well so
when you come in for a tour at Zappos in
our lobby area the first thing you'll
see is the Zappos library there's about
30 or 40 titles there these are two of
the titles that you'll see except it's
not a lending library
it's a giving library and we give the
books out freely to our employees as
well as to visitors because one of our
core values is to pursue growth and
learning so at the end of the tour a lot
of visitors will take home three or four
titles that they think are relevant to
their business or their own personal
life and two of the books that are some
of the titles rotate in and out two of
the books that are always there are good
to great and tribal leadership and in
fact we even partnered with the authors
of tribal leadership you can download
the audio version of the book for free
from the Zappos website and we in fact
teach classes on each of these books to
our employees and the reason why these
two books we really believe strongly in
is because the author's researched and
looked at what separated the great
companies in terms of long term
financial performance from just the good
ones and they were actually surprised by
their findings it wasn't at all what
they expected they found that the great
companies had two important ingredients
that the good ones and mediocre ones
generally did not have and the first
important ingredient was that the great
companies all had strong cultures and
for us we formalized the definition of
our culture into ten core values and we
actually didn't always have core values
at Zappos we've been around for eleven
years and it wasn't until five or six
years into it that we rolled out our
core values because it was kind of
something that a bunch of us myself
personally resisted because it felt like
one of those big corporate
things to do and you know a lot of
corporations have they might call them
core values or guiding principles or so
on but the problem is usually they're
very lofty sounding they kind of read
like a press release the marketing
department put out they sound just like
their competitors and maybe you learn
about it on day one of your job but then
it becomes this meaningless plaque on
the lobby wall well we wanted to come up
with committable core values and by
committable meaning we're willing to
hire or fire people based on those
values completely independent of their
actual job performance and when you use
that criteria it's actually a really
hard list to come up with it took us a
year to come up with it
and it wasn't just a few executives that
spent a long weekend at an off-site
somewhere and came up with the core
values but instead I just emailed the
entire company and asked our employees
what should our values be got a whole
bunch of different responses back and
went back and forth for about a year and
then he eventually came up with our list
of 10 core values so this is our list of
10 core values and we actually have
interview questions for each and every
one of these core values and actually
one of the cool things that I liked
about the list we ended up with is if
you do a Google search for any one of
these core values by itself in almost
all the cases Zappos is the number one
search result whereas for take almost
any other company do a search for one of
their core values and page after page
after page you won't see that company
name show up so the one that actually
probably trips us up the most during the
hiring process is this last one be
humble because there's a lot of really
smart talented people out there that are
also egotistical and you know for us
it's not a question we just won't hire
them whereas the conversation at most
other companies would be well this
person might be kind of annoying and rub
you the wrong way but he's going to add
a lot of value and therefore we should
hire that person and that one person may
or may not bring the company culture
downhill but I think if you keep making
compromises like that over and over and
over again that's why most large
companies don't have great company
cultures but it's actually probably the
one that's hardest to actually ask a
national interview question for because
you can't just say how humble are you
and they say I'm the most humble person
the whole wide world
and so but what one of the ways we test
for this is a lot of our candidates
actually are from out of town and so
while picking them up from the airport
in Zappos shuttle give them the tour and
then they'll spend the entire day
interviewing well at the end of the day
of interviews the recruiter will circle
back with the shuttle driver and ask how
they were treated and it doesn't matter
how well the day of interviews when if
they didn't treat the shuttle driver
well then we won't hire them it's not
even a question
so I'll give some examples of other of
interview questions we asked number
three create fun and a little weirdness
one of our interview questions is
actually on a scale one to ten how weird
are you and you know if you answer one
you might be a little bit too
straight-laced for the Zappos culture
the answer ten you might be too
psychotic for us but it's actually not
so much the actual number we care about
our whole belief is that everyone's a
little weird somehow and this is really
more just a fun always saying that we
really recognize and celebrate each
person's individuality and we want their
true personality to come out and shine
in the workplace now there's so many
people in corporate America where
they're a different person at home on
weekends versus when they show up into
the office on Mondays and you end up
leaving a little part of themselves or
in a lot of cases a big part of
themselves at home and that leads to
discussions about work/life separation
or work-life balance and for us actually
rather than worry about work/life
separation we really think about in
terms of work/life integration we want
the person to be the same person at home
or in the office because what we found
is that's when the great ideas come out
that's when their creativity shines and
that's when true friendships are formed
not just co-worker relationships and
that's really what when people are in
that environment
that's when the passion comes out and
that's really what's driven a lot of our
growth over the years and core value
number four be adventurous creative and
open-minded so one of our interview
questions here is on a scale one to ten
how lucky are you in life one is I don't
know why bad things always seem to
happen to me and ten is I don't know why
good things always seem to happen to me
well we don't want to hire the ones
because there
bad luck and we don't want bad luck to
come to Zappos that I wouldn't be good
no but this was actually inspired by a
research study that I read about several
years earlier where they actually asked
that exact same question to a random
group of people and they got you know
some one some tens a bunch of answers in
between and then afterwards they had
them do a task and the task was to go
through a newspaper and count the number
of photos that were in that newspaper
but what the participants didn't know
was that it was actually a fake
newspaper and sprinkled throughout the
newspaper were these headlines that
would say things like if you're reading
this now you can stop the answers 37
plus collect an extra hundred dollars
and what they found was that the people
that consider themselves unlucky in life
generally never notice the headlines
they went through the task and you know
eventually came up with the right answer
whereas the people that consider
themselves lucky in life generally
stopped early and made the extra hundred
dollars so the takeaway is that it's not
so much that people are inherently lucky
or unlucky in life but luck is really
more about being open to opportunity
beyond just how the task or situation
presents itself so that's why we asked
that question for core value number four
be creative adventurous and open-minded
and so one of our other core values is
about being open and honest it's really
just all about transparency and we
really try to be as transparent as
possible to our customers to our
employees to our vendors as well so for
our customers for example we hold a
quarterly All Hands meeting for our
employees and we actually livestream
that on the internet so anyone can tune
in and employees will ask questions
about company financials or what brands
were going to carry and so on the other
thing we do is when there's a reporter
that wants to do a story on us whether
it's for TV or magazine or so on
you know most companies most
corporations what would happen is
they're escorted around by PR person and
the PR person says you can talk to that
VP over there and that person in
communications over there everyone else
is off limits don't talk to anyone else
whereas what we do is we give a tour and
at the end of the tour we say
bathrooms over there lunch rooms over
there walk around talk to whoever you
feel like and when you're done come find
me and the reason we're comfortable
doing that is because we know that
employees understand the long term
vision of the company and we know that
employees
we've hired their personal values match
the corporate values so every employee
is just automatically living the brand
and you know they're not going to we
don't do media training and so when the
reporter talks to ten different
employees they're not going to get the
exact same phrases or sound bytes in and
so on but what they are going to find is
consistency in every employee's attitude
and more importantly the authenticity
and their interactions and so that's why
we we just tell anyone just walk around
and talk to whoever you want because
that's what we're comfortable with with
our employees we have a monthly
newsletter called ask anything where
it's literally that employees can ask
about financials or brands or whatever
and we'll find the best person to answer
them and then put that all in newsletter
and we send that out to the entire
company once a month for our vendors we
work with 1,500 different brands and
they have access to this back-end system
we call the extranet where they can log
in and view the exact same information
our own buyers and merchandisers can
view so they can view on hand inventory
sales profitability markdowns and so on
and when we first rolled this out the
response from the vendor community was
wow this is great but aren't you worried
this information is going to get into
the hands of competitors and
realistically I'm sure some of the
information does eventually find its way
into the hands of competitors but on the
flip side we now have an extra 1500
pairs of eyes helping us co manage our
business and they're not on our payroll
and so for us we found that the benefits
far outweigh any perceived risk because
a lot of times they'll catch stuff that
our own buyers are merchandisers might
miss if there's some style that's
suddenly taking off and you know our
buyers have portfolios of twenty to
thirty brands so they may not catch it
in time so you know this is a common
reaction get we get sometimes okay happy
for you Zappos you have this great
culture made the fortune hundred best
companies to work for lists but the
stuff you're talking about would never
work at my company
and when people come to our offices
they're like oh okay
I I get it but you know the way you're
you and allow your employees to do XYZ
would never fly at my company but what I
found really interesting about the
research from good to great and tribal
leadership is that they found that it
actually doesn't matter what your core
values are what matters is that you have
them and the power you get is out of the
alignment that you get when you have the
entire organization act in a certain way
and have kind of a default way of
thinking and and that's what I found
really interesting and for us what the
real power came from when the values
become integrated into our everyday
language and we don't even notice it but
not a day goes by where we don't use our
core values just in our everyday
conversation on a day to day basis so
it's really that's the real power of
having a strong culture of having
alignment throughout the entire
organization and I'm going to make this
presentation available because another
reaction we get sometimes now I wanted
to include these other stories is Zappos
you're an Internet company special rules
apply to Internet companies and some of
these stories in here are actually from
companies in completely different
industries and completely different
types of companies and one of the other
ways we're transparent is actually we
have the separate entity called Zappos
insights it's actually its own website
Zappos insights calm where we actually
help other companies figure out how to
build their own strong cultures and
figure out their own core values and
there's a monthly video subscription
service there's also these one day and
two days seminars where people and
companies from all over the world
actually fly in and go through these
exercises and one of the stories I
included in there is a company that went
through about a year ago called the
Atlanta refrigeration company they're
based in Atlanta Georgia and they do
refrigeration repairs out in the field
so in some ways you can't think of a
more opposite company or industry than
Zappos and they went back focused on
company culture focused on delivering
better customer service and now they're
reporting back that their customers are
happier their employees are happier they
even send us before-and-after pictures
of their offices and in a down economy
their revenues and profits are up and so
it's for us it's just been really
interesting
rewarding to see this whole idea of
happiness as a business model work in
other industries and other companies so
going back to a good to great tribal
leadership I said the author's
researched and they found there were two
important ingredients that separated the
great companies in terms of long term
financial performance from just the good
ones
the first thing greening was the great
and companies all had strong cultures
and the second one is actually really
counterintuitive at least to me and what
they found was that the second important
ingredient was that these great
companies all had a vision that had a
higher purpose beyond just money or
profits or being number one in a market
and the weird thing an ironic thing
about that is actually by having a
higher purpose it actually enabled these
companies to generate more profits in
the long run and sometimes I'll be
speaking at an entrepreneur conference
for example and I'll get approached
afterwards where entrepreneurs will ask
what's a good market to get into where I
can make a lot of money and my advice to
them is rather than have money be your
primary motivator instead think about
what would you be so passion about doing
that you'd be happy doing it for 10
years even if you never made it any
money from it and that's what you should
be doing and if you actually do that it
actually in an equate greatly increases
your chances of making more money in the
long run because your passion is what's
going to get you through the tough times
your passion is going to rub off on your
employees and your your suppliers and
the customers are going to sense it and
because it has this whole ripple domino
effect so I'd like to say chase the
vision not the money there was a movie
that came out several years ago called
notorious I think it lasted a week in a
theater and I may have been the only
person that saw this movie play in the
movie Puff Daddy
says to rapper biggie smalls also known
as notorious b.i.g don't chase the paper
chase the drain I just want an excuse to
put this picture up you're in a business
talk so if you're an entrepreneur
I don't think about what would you be so
passion about doing that you'd be happy
doing it for 10 years even if you never
made any money right and that's what you
should be doing and if you have
employees that report to you then think
about what's the higher vision and
greater purpose in their work beyond
just money or profits or being number
one in a market because that's what's
actually going to help inspire them and
you know there's a lot of consultants
and books that talk about how to
motivate employees and there always
seems to be a new trend and in you know
the latest management fads and you know
there's different ways to motivate
employees a lot of corporate America
actually motivates employees through
fear
you can also motivate employees through
incentives and you can motivate
employees through recognition and all of
those things work up to a certain extent
but what we found at Zappos is there's a
huge difference between motivation and
inspiration and if you can inspire your
employees by having a higher purpose in
the company beyond just money or profits
or being number one and marketing if you
can inspire employees by having
corporate core values that match their
own personal values and not just the
stated core values but the actual
practice core values then you can
accomplish so much more and you don't
really need to worry about the
motivation part of it the inspiration
just will will accomplish much much more
than the motivation part so this is the
evolution of our brand at Zappos in 1999
it was just okay let's just our vision
was let's just sell a lot of shoes it's
all going to be about selection and then
four years into it in 2003 we all sat
around and asked ourselves what do we
want to be when we grow up do we want to
be about shoes or do we want to be about
something more meaningful and that's
when we decided okay let's build the
Zappos brand to be about the very best
customer service and customer experience
and a funny thing happened when we
communicated this to our employees we
found that suddenly employees were a lot
more passionate and excited about the
company and when customers called they
could sense the person on the other end
the line truly wanted to provide great
service and wasn't there just for a
paycheck we found that when vendors came
and visit us they wanted to visit us
more often in
longer and so all these things had this
kind of multiplicative snowball effect
that drove a lot of our growth over the
years and in 2005 was when we switched
from culture just being important to
culture being the number one priority in
the company with the belief that if we
get the culture right then most of the
other stuff delivering great customer
service building a long-term enduring
brand that will just take care of itself
and then 2007 we start seeing that okay
what are different ways we can provide
great customer service some companies
focus more on the technology and
efficiency part of it well we decided
instead of going to high tech approach
to go to high touch approach and really
focus on building personal emotional
connections and then 2009 we took a step
back and realize okay customer service
is about making customers happy company
culture is about making employees happy
let's just tie it all together and
really have our vision be about
delivering happiness to the world and
then from that expanding vision that
would led to the development of Zappos
insights comm which is a completely
different business doesn't have anything
to do with e-commerce or selling shoes
online so wanted to tell another Pizza
story and this actually happened a few
years ago in Santa Monica California and
I was actually at a Skechers conference
and it's one of the brands we worked
with one of the Footwear brands and it
was a long day and at the end of the day
a bunch of us decided to go bar-hopping
there were three people from Skechers
and three people from Zappos including
myself I'd never been bar-hopping in the
Santa Monica area before so we went to
the first bar and someone ordered a
round of drinks and then someone I can't
remember who decide to order a round of
shots
so been a long day we took the shots
finish the round of drinks and then we
went to the second bar and someone else
ordered a round of drinks to pay back
for that first round of drinks and so
when else order a second round of shots
to pay back for that first round of
shots and we're looking at it and we
determined that you can't waste alcohol
so we took the shots and finish the
drinks and then went to the third bar
and I'm actually unclear how many shots
four drinks we had after that but what I
do know is that in California last
all is I think it's to a and is that you
I am okay I'm from Vegas so last call
isn't in the dictionary there but so
that's 2 a.m. and anyway so finally
let's go on I don't know how many bars
we've been to and finally start walking
back to the hotel room and as we're
walking back to the hotel room one of
the girls from Skechers asked if we
wanted to all share a pepperoni pizza
and she was so exciting we're like yeah
sure and she's like oh I'm so excited I
actually checked it out on the room
service menu before we left it was on
page 17 item number two and I know when
it comes it's going to be super hot and
I don't want to burn the roof of my
mouth so I'm just gonna blow on it and
let the aroma slowly walked into my nose
and she kept talking about engage super
excited and it was only a five minute
walk but it seemed much longer than that
could she would not stop talking about
this pepperoni pizza so anyways we
finally wind up in someone's hotel room
she's super excited calls room service
and then 10 seconds later hangs up the
phone all dejected and I asked her
what's wrong and she said apparently
this hotel doesn't deliver hot food
after 11 p.m. and she was like oh you
have no idea how much I was craving that
pepperoni pizza and I was like I think
we all have a pretty good idea
and but she was still really sad and
trying to think that okay how do you
cheer up and then I tell her the story
of like how in college I used to make
pizza and this guy named Alfred and and
this is how we met and at the end of my
story she looks at me and she's like
that's still not helpful right now so no
Fred who's also from Zappos you know are
kind of brainstorming and then we come
up with the best idea ever we say oh
call Zappos call Zappos we're all about
the best customer service we'll take
care of you and really in art inebriated
state of mind we thought that was the
funniest thing ever and so so she
actually takes us up on our dare and you
know puts it on speakerphone and you
know says rep answers thanks for calling
Zappos how can I help you the rest of us
are in the background trying to like be
quiet enough not laugh and and she's
like oh thank goodness you're answered
I know it's 3m but I'm in Santa Monica
right now in this hotel that doesn't
serve hot food after 11:00 p.m. then
craving this pepperoni pizza on the room
service menu I'm looking at it right now
page 17 item number two is there
anything you can do for me well first
there was an awkward silence and then in
the rough said you know you called
Zappos right we sell shoes we sell
clothes but we don't sell pizza yet and
she's like I know but I heard you all
about the best customer service and the
rep said ok hold on and put us on hold
for two minutes and then came back
listing the five closest places in the
Santa Monica area that we're still open
and delivering pizza at that hour now
well first of all I I hesitated a little
to tell the story because I don't want
all of you to start calling Zappos and
ordering pizza froze but you know
clearly we don't have a process and
procedure for late night drunk pizza
orders but it it just goes back to I
just think it's a fun story to
illustrate that if you get the culture
right then most of the other stuff like
delivering great customer service and
building your brand one story at a time
one phone call at a time just happens
naturally on
you know these types of stories we're
creating at Zappos literally thousands
of thousands of times every single day
and that's how we built our brand over
the years and these are you know
questions that we think about how do we
create more happy memories for customers
and how do we listen more positive
emotions and really were in the memories
and emotions business and stories
business and then we also think about
how do we keep thinking differently and
expanding what business were actually
and how do we think bigger and think
differently and one of my favorite
stories is about Cirque de Soleil where
you know they completely redefine the
circus business prior to the Cirque de
Soleil to have a better circus men more
elephants bigger elephants and the
market research surveys if they did them
would be exiting you know doing exit
polls and they'd be like were the
elephants of sufficient quantity and
sufficient size and you know and then
that that would tell them how to build a
better surface and the surface light
just thought completely you know outside
the box so anyways just wanted to wrap
up it and actually take a step back from
all of this business talk and have you
guys actually think about this for
yourselves what is your goal in life and
like think for yourself personally what
is your actual goal in life and when I
ask different people this question
actually get a whole bunch of different
answers back some people will say they
want to say grow company especially at
entrepreneur conferences some people say
they want to be healthy and then I'll
ask them why so whatever your goal in
life is ask yourself why and then people
come up with another set of answers they
want to retire early or run faster and
then I'll ask them why again and so
whatever your answer is just as yourself
why and what's interesting is if you ask
why enough times
almost everyone comes up with the same
answer and it's they're pursuing they're
going like this because they believe it
ultimately make them happier so I
started a few years ago reading about
this whole field of research called the
science of happiness the official name
is actually positive psychology but it's
based on actual research that's been
done not so I'm not saying talking about
go to the you know self-help section of
books or in think positive and you'll be
happy but actual research that's been
done
and as I was reading about this prior to
1998 most of psychology was about how do
you take people that had something wrong
with them and make them more normal but
almost nobody bothered to study how to
take normal people and make them happier
so as I was reading about this one the
consistent findings from the research is
that people are actually very bad at
predicting what will make them happy on
a sustainable sustainable basis most
people most people think oh once I get X
then I'll be happy once I achieve X then
I'll be happy when the research shows
you know for example lottery winners
look at their happiness right before
winning the lottery and then a year
later a year later it's the same or
maybe a little bit lower than before so
people are bad at predicting what will
make them happy and then you know start
to think that well you know at Zappos
there's a science behind a lot of stuff
that we do in terms of website
conversion customer acquisition metrics
repeat customer behavior and if the
ultimate goal is happiness what if some
percent of time was actually spent just
reading up on the research that's been
done how can that not only help
personally but how can it help the
company in terms of making customers
happy and making employees happy because
it's not as simple as just asking
customers or employees what would make
you happy you know a lot of people go
through life trying to get to that
ultimate destination of happiness but a
lot of people never get there and other
people that do get there a lot of most
of them find that it's actually very
short-lived not quite what they were
expecting what if by reading up on the
science happiness learning a little bit
about the research you can kind of
shortcut something and go to the
happiness much faster so just want to
share some of the frameworks that happen
is that I thought were most interesting
from the research that I read first
framework is happiness is really just
about four things perceived control
perceived progress connectedness meaning
the number and depth of your
relationships and being part of
something bigger than yourself and
what's interesting is you can apply this
to business as well you know connecting
this goes back to company culture I'll
give a quick example for perceived
progress we used to hire people in our
merchandising department at entry-level
and then give them promotions every
eighteen months and you know they get
trained and certified and so on and then
in three years they become a buyer well
we changed that a few years ago so that
instead of promotion
every 18 months we gave them smaller
promotions every six months nothing
changed if they still took three years
to become a buyer they still had to go
get certified and so on but we found
employees were much happier because
there was that ongoing sense a perceived
progress and it cost the company nothing
to do that Maslow's hierarchy there's a
book called peek by chip Conley pjk
where he condenses it down to three
levels and so for example for employees
it's do they think of their work as a
job or career or calling and our whole
goal let's apples is to move them up
that pyramid so that they're still
employees at Zappos ten years from now
and then the last framework wanted to
share real quickly the three types of
happiness pleasure engagement and
meaning and the first type I like to
call the Rockstar type of happiness
because it's all about chasing that next
high and it's great if you can sustain
it the problem is it's very hard to
sustain
unless you're basically a rock star and
what the research has shown is that as
soon as the source of stimuli goes away
that's giving you that high as soon as
that goes away your happiness just
plummets and drops right back down to
wherever it was before
it's a shortest lasting type of
happiness the second is called flow and
it's about we've all experienced this
it's about those moments when time just
flies because you're so into whatever
you're doing for some people it's
running for other people might be
painting and it's three hours past seems
like only twenty minutes have passed and
professional athletes refer to it as
being in the zone where peak engagement
meets peak performance and other
characteristics associated with it are
you lose a sense of self-consciousness
because self-consciousness or even self
and basically the strategies there is
notice when it happens and then change
your environment your friends where you
live your job and so on to have that
happen more often and the research shows
that that's the second longest lasting
type of happiness and the third type is
the longest lasting type it's about
being part of something bigger than
yourself and for some people might be
volunteering for your favorite charity
for example and what I found interesting
is most people go through life chasing
after the first type of happiness
thinking once I could sustain that on an
ongoing basis which is next to
impossible then I'll worry about the
second type and then if I ever get
around to it then I'll worry about the
third type when based on the research
data
and purely on the research that the
proper strategy is figure out the third
type first layer on top of that the
second type and then anytime you
experience the first type just icing on
the cake so some books I would recommend
for copy of this presentation email Tony
at delivering happiness book comm make
sure to include the book at the end in
the URL or the email address and for a
culture book that I talked about make
sure to include your mailing address
because it's a physical book and will
send it to you next time you're in Vegas
go to tours zappas come to get a free
tour will pick you up and you know the
subtitle of my book is the title of my
book is delivering happiness the
subtitle is a path to profits passion
and purpose and you need all three in
order to have a business that will
continue to grow and companies you know
so many companies in corporate America
focus on just the profits part of it and
forget about the passion and purpose and
that actually ends up hurting their
ability to generate profits in the long
term and then had this weird aha moment
where happiness you know is really about
being able to combine pleasure passion
and purpose and so you know this whole
idea of happiness as a business model is
something that through the book we want
to spread to other organizations and
other companies and I think we're just
at the beginning of the very special
time where we're all hyper connected
information travels so quickly company's
culture companies brand or that lag time
is becoming less and less and really
that's how we've approached things at
Zappos and you know just want to leave
you with think about what percent of
your time do you want to spend reading
up on the signs of happiness and how can
that help yourself personally your brand
or your business you know the research
shows that companies that have a higher
purpose actually generate more profits
in the long term and people that have a
higher purpose actually are happier now
think about what is your company's
higher purpose and what is your own
higher purpose and if through this
presentation you've been inspired to
make customers happier through customer
service or make employees happier by
focusing more on culture and and
figuring out the vision or just make
yourself happier by reading up more on
this whole signs of happiness if any of
those things have happened then
I'll have done my part in helping us
fulfill our own higher purpose which is
all about delivering happiness to the
world thank you very much